in this video Martin and I are going to
talk about Ai and answer the question
are we there yet and stick around to the
end where Jeff and I will be explaining
how we use AI in our everyday lives
hopefully you've seen some of my
security videos on this channel well I
sure have well great and I've seen a lot
of your AI videos as well so we're going
to have a conversation about AI are we
there yet well so I think we're kind of
there because one definition of AI is
basically the simulation of intelligent
behavior in computers and we've kind of
done that what do you think Martin yes I
would agree with that definition but are
we there yet absolutely not I didn't
think so and the reason I think that is
because of something called a g i which
is an acronym for artificial general
intelligence and this really describes
an AI system that is equivalent to a
human and it is diverse as a human and
can do anything that a human can do at
least as well or better and I don't
think we are there yet okay maybe not so
let's take a look at some examples of
where we've come from and where we're
going so maybe a hypothetical yeah I've
got a good one I've got to go on so
let's just consider I also write some
numbers down here let's see this if I
put this up and then let's do three one
two five if I could tell you in my head
just like that the answer to that math
equation
is that intelligence it's really
impressive it's a nice parlor trick but
you know I've got a calculator that can
do the same thing and I'm really not
ready to declare that my calculator is
sentient it's not artificially
intelligent so maybe not there yet but
it's a great example well how about I'll
tell you a story from in my middle
school days my science teacher
considered intelligence would be if you
knew all the elements in the periodic
table where they went what their atomic
numbers were how to spell them and their
abbreviations and you could place all of
that where it belonged and that would
have been considered intelligent was she
right with the greatest respect to your
science teacher I don't think that's
intelligence either I think what you've
just described there
is a database lookup yeah
how about then something a bit more
advanced than that something that takes
years and years to get good at like a
chess Grand Master and I think of all of
the time that you have to invest to
learn all of the patterns all of the
moves all of the strategy is a chest
Grandmaster and a real example of
intelligence yeah I think most people
would say somebody who is the best in
the world at chess is a genius so you
would think if you're a genius you're
intelligent but guess what IBM did this
trick in 1997 where we created a
computer we call Deep Blue and deep blue
was able to beat the best chess player
in the world handily so that already if
that's your bar we already passed it yet
again we kind of feel like we're left
empty we're still not feeling there yet
so what is the classic question the
classic problem to solve you're going to
tell me the cheering test right I am
going to tell you the touring test
that's exactly right and what is the
touring test for those who don't know
with a touring test you basically have a
user here and they cannot see who it is
that they are typing to so they're
typing messages back and forth and they
may be talking to another person or they
may be talking to a computer and if it's
indistinguishable when they have their
Communications and they can't tell if
they're talking to another person or
talking to a computer then we would
declare game over the computer has has
achieved artificial intelligence so if
we could ever do that then we'd be there
right well this one is a little bit
disputed as to have we passed the Turing
test or not but in 2014 technically some
people say that we did with a chat bot
that simulated a 13 year old boy well so
that's setting the bar kind of low 13
year old boy you and I used to be one
one of those so I I think maybe we want
to set the bar higher but uh but have
would we consider other Technologies
maybe that have raised the bar further
towards the touring test I mean I I
taught with chats gbt daily and
sometimes I could be convinced that as a
real person so I think there have been a
lot of advances in that kind of area I
think so I talked to chat GPT regularly
too nobody else will talk to me so at
least at least that one that hasn't
failed me yet so that's that's a good
example clearly the bar has been raised
if we ask the question are we there yet
or not I feel like it's a little bit
like we move the Finish Line every time
we get close to it as soon as we cross
it then we say yeah but that's not quite
there yet so we kind of had this this
sense of if you look at all of these
things together we have these sort of
siled savants we have something that's
really great at arithmetic we have
something that's really great at
memorization and recall something that's
great at a narrowly bounded game that is
quite complex but still has very
specific rules that can be
mathematically described or we're
talking about a kind of general
intelligence emotional intelligence that
would be required to pass the touring
test and things like that so we we
continue to to have these developments
in individual areas but putting it all
together that's your AGI but I think
it's also worth pointing out that the
development curve for AI it just seems
very recently even this year is just
going faster and faster than ever before
and we are getting closer and closer to
this idea of general intelligence moving
away from where we have everything siled
we're like deep blue which is deeply
siled to just chess to now these AI
systems that are really getting closer
and closer to be able to accomplish much
more of what we do as humans I think
you're right when I was in school we
talked about artificial intelligence and
it was always about something that was
about five or ten years away and then 10
years later it was is another five or
ten years away but I feel like we're
actually narrowing the Gap in the last
few years it's been this steep curve
toward what we would consider General
artificial intelligence so are we there
yet
no but we've never been closer awesome
hey hey Jeff we didn't we didn't get to
the bit where you tell me how you're
using AI in your everyday life I did
forget that so I actually have a
self-driving car that brings me to work
it's basically a computer that takes me
places how about you how do you use AI I
realize that I'm not a very good
photographer but I'm much better at AI
prompting so I just prompt what I want
in a picture and it generates a
beautiful professional photograph it's
fantastic great and I bet those watching
this video don't realize that in fact
you and I aren't here all of this has
been scripted by a chat bot and we've
been replaced
how about you how are you using AI in
your everyday life let us know in the
comments